you could call tonight the Triumph of
the Transformers or maybe the battle for
attention with two thunderous
developments within a handful of hours
of each other one from Google Deep Mind
and then open AI But ultimately the
bigger picture is this the exponential
advance of artificial intelligence and
its applications shows no sign of
slowing if you were hoping for a quiet
year tonight just shattered that
peaceful vision of course of course I
could have done a video on either Gemini
1.5 which is arguably as of tonight the
most performant language model in the
world or Sora the text to video model
open AI released shortly after Google
possibly as a purposeful grab of the
spotlight possibly coincidentally both
developments are game-changing but with
the technical paper of soraa due out
later today it allows us to give Gemini
1.5 its due attention yes I've read all
58 pages of the technical paper as well
as four papers Linked In the appendices
in my search for how it got the results
it did I've got 62 notes so let's dive
in here is the big development Gemini
1.5 can recall and reason over
information across millions of tokens of
context or in another example they gave
22 hours of audio or 3 hours of lowf
frame rate video or 6 to 8es of normal
frame rate videos I don't want to bury
the headline we're talking about near
perfect retrieval of facts and details
up to at least 10 million tokens
performance did not dip at 10 million
tokens indeed the trend line got
substantially better for reference in
text 10 million tokens would be about
7.5 million words to wrap your head
around how many words 10 million tokens
is that's around 2% of all of English
language Wikipedia and again just for
emphasis we're talking at least 10
million tokens now admittedly in the
blog post and paper they do talk about
latency tradeoffs with that many tokens
and no in case you're wondering Gemini
1.5 isn't currently widely available
just to a limited group of developers
and Enterprise customers in case that
puts you off though Google promised this
significant improvements in speed are
also on the horizon but before we get
back to the paper how about a demo so
you can see Gemini 1.5 Pro in action
this is a demo of long context
understanding an experimental feature in
our newest model Gemini 1.5 Pro we'll
walk through a screen recording of
example prompts using a 402 page PDF of
the Apollo 11 transcript which comes out
to almost 330,000
tokens we started by uploading the
Apollo PDF into Google AI
studio and asked find three comedic
moments list quotes from this transcript
and
Emoji this screen capture is sped up
this timer shows exactly how long it
took to process each prompt and keep in
mind that processing times will
vary the model responded with three
quotes like this one from Michael
Collins I'll bet you a cup of coffee on
it if we go back to the transcript we
can see the model found this exact quote
and extracted the comedic moment
accurately then we tested a multimodal
prompt we gave it this drawing of a
scene we were thinking of and asked what
moment is
this
the model correctly identified it as
Neil's first steps on the moon I'll
feature more demos later in the video
but notice that the inference time in
this sped up video wasn't that bad and
yes for anyone paying attention this is
Gemini 1.5 Pro what that means is that
any results you're seeing will soon be
improved upon by Gemini 1.5 Ultra
remember that we have Gemini Nano then
Gemini Pro the mediumsized model and
finally Gemini Ultra well how did Google
Deep Mind achieve this feat they say in
the introduction ction that the model
incorporates a novel mixture of experts
architecture as well as major advances
in training and serving infrastructure
that allows it to push the boundaries of
efficiency reasoning and long context
performance in case you're wondering
that long context again refers to that
huge volume of text image video and
audio data that Gemini 1.5 can ingest
but I will admit that when I first read
this introduction I thought they have
used the Mamba architecture that was
build as the successor architecture to
the Transformer and I did a video on it
on the 1st of January it too achieved
amazing results in Long context tasks
and outperformed the Transformer the
Transformer is of course the te in GPT
however by the time I finished the paper
it was pretty clear that it wasn't based
on Mamba and it took me a little while
to figure it out and reading quite a few
papers cited in the appendices but I
think I've got a pretty good guess as to
what the architecture is based on anyway
what is the next interesting point from
the paper well Google does confirm that
Gemini 1.5 Pro requires significantly
less compute to train than a 1.0 Ultra
so it's arguably better than Ultra and
we'll see the benchmarks in a moment but
requires significantly less compute to
train that is maybe why Google Deep Mind
were able to get out Gemini 1.5 Pro so
soon after announcing Gemini 1.0 and
don't forget that Gemini 1.0 Ultra as
part of Gemini Advance was only released
to the public a week ago that's when my
review video came out Google by the way
gives you a 2-month free trial of Gemini
advance and I now think part of the
reason for that is to give them time to
incorporate Gemini 1.5 Pro before that
free trial ends and here is the first
bombshell graphic in the paper this is
the task of finding a needle in a Hast
stack across text video and audio modal
ities a fact or passcode might be buried
at varying depths of sequences of
varying lengths as you can see for text
these lengths went up to 10 million
tokens for audio it was up to 22 hours
and video up to 3 hours the models would
then be tested on that fact as you can
see the performance was incredible with
just five missed facts for reference I
went back to the original Benchmark
which I've cited in two previous videos
to compare here is gpc4 perform perance
at up to only
128,000 tokens as you can see as the
sequence length gets to around 80,000
words or 100,000 tokens the performance
especially Midway through the sequence
degrades at the time anthropics claw 2.1
performed even worse although they did
subsequently come up with a prompt
engineering hack to reduce most of these
incorrect recalls but are you ready for
the next bombshell they see Gemini 1.5
Pro output performing all competing
models across all modalities even when
these models are augmented with external
retrieval methods in the lingo that's
rag in layman's terms that's grabbing
relevant text to assist them in
answering the questions of course with a
long context Gemini 1.5 Pro is just
simply ingesting the entire document and
now for one of the key tables in the
paper you might be wondering and indeed
Google Deep Mind were wondering if this
extra performance in Long context tasks
would mean a tradeoff for other types of
task text vision and audio tasks that
didn't require long context the answer
was no Gemini 1.5 Pro is better on
average compared to 1.0 Pro across text
vision and audio in other words it
hasn't just got better at long context
it's got better at a range of other
tasks it beats Gemini 1.0 Pro 100% of
the time in text benchmarks and most of
the time in vision and audio benchmarks
and wait there's more it also beats most
of the time Gemini 1.0 Ultra in Tex
benchmarks of course at this point if
you only care about standard benchmarks
and not about long context it's more or
less a draw with Gemini 1.0 Ultra it has
a win rate of
54.8% and it would also be pretty much a
tie with GPT 4 but I think it's fair to
say that once you bring in Long context
capabilities it is now indisputably the
best language model in the world I
should caveat that with it's the best
language model that is accessible to
some people out there of course behind
the scenes Google deepmind have gini 1.5
Ultra which would surely be better than
1.5 Pro and I know what you're thinking
this is Google so maybe they use some
cookie prompting method to get these
results well I've read the entire paper
and it doesn't seem so to me these are
genuine like for like comparisons to 1.0
Pro and 1.0 Ultra now I have looked in
the appendices and the exact wording of
the prompts may have been different to
for example gp4 it does seem borderline
impossible to get perfectly like for
like comparisons but from everything I
can see this does seem to be a genuine
result now before you get too excited as
you can see the Benchmark results for
1.5 Pro in nonong context tasks is
pretty impressive but we're not
completely changing the game here they
haven't come up with some sort of
architecture that just crushes in every
time we're still dealing with a familiar
language model for most tasks but before
I give you my architecture speculations
time for another demo this time
analyzing a 1 frame per second 44-minute
movie this is a demo of long context
understanding an experimental feature in
our newest model Gemini 1.5 Pro we'll
walk through a screen recording of
example prompts using a 44-minute buster
Katon film which comes out to over
600,000 tokens in Google AI Studio we
uploaded the video and asked find the
moment when a piece of paper is removed
from the person's pocket and tell me
some key information on it with the time
code this screen capture is sped up and
this timer shows exactly how long it
took to process each prompt and keep in
mind that processing times will vary the
model gave us this response explaining
that the piece of paper is a pwn ticket
from Goldman and Company Pond Brokers
with the date and cost and it gave us
this time code
1201 when we pulled up that time code we
found it was correct the model had found
the exact moment the piece of paper is
removed from the person's pocket and it
extracted text accurately next we gave
it this drawing of a scene we were
thinking of and asked what is the time
code when this happens the model
returned this time code
1534 we pulled that up and found that it
was the correct scene like all
generative models responses vary and
won't always be perfect but notice how
we didn't have to explain what was
happening in the drawing Gemini being
multimodal from the ground up is really
shining here and I do think we have to
take a step back and say wow at the
moment this might mean 6 to 8 minutes of
a 24 or 30 frames per second video on
YouTube but still successfully picking
out that Minor Detail in that short of a
time is truly groundbreaking given that
Google owns YouTube you will soon be
querying say AI explain videos okay time
for my guess about how they managed it
in terms of architecture well first they
say simply it's a sparse mixture of
expert Transformer base model those are
fairly standard terms described in other
videos of mine but then here's the key
sentence Gemini 1.5 Pro also Builds on
the following research and the language
model research in this broader
literature now I had a look at most of
these papers particularly the recent
ones and one stood out this paper by
Jang atow came out just over a month ago
and remember Google says that Gemini 1.5
Pro Builds on this work now building on
something that came out that recently is
pretty significant of course Google have
their own massive body of literature on
sparse mixture of experts and indeed
invented the Transformer architecture
but this tweet tonight from one of the
key authors of Gemini 1.5 does point to
things developing more rapidly recently
Prav shyam said this just a few months
ago Nikolai Dennis and I were exploring
ways to dramatically increase our
context length little did we know that
our ideas would ship in production so
quickly so yes Google has worked going
back years on sparse mixture of expert
models and yes too many people
underestimated the years of Innovations
going on quietly at Google in this case
for inference but for the purposes of
time this is the paper I'm going to
focus on this is the one by Jang
released around a month ago it's of
course mixture of experts from mistal AI
That's that brand new French outfit with
a multi-billion Euro valuation and no I
don't just think it's relevant because
of the date and the fact it's sparse and
a mixture of experts mixture of experts
in a nutshell being when you have a
bigger model comprised of multiple
smaller blocks or experts when the
tokens come in they are dynamically
rooted to just two in most cases
relevant experts or blocks so the entire
model isn't active during inference it's
lightweight and effective but no that's
not the reason why I focused on this
paper it's because of this section 3.2
long range performance mix TR managed to
achieve a 100% retrieval accuracy
regardless of the context length and
also regardless of the position or depth
of the password of course mistol only
proved that up to 32,000 tokens and
Google I believe have taken it much
further that's my theory let me know in
the comments if you think I'm right
Google do say they also made
improvements in terms of data
optimization and systems but if you're
looking for more info on compute or the
training data set good luck other than
saying that the compute is significantly
less than Gemini 1.0 Ultra and that
Gemini 1.5 Pro is trained on a variety
of multimodal and multilingual data they
don't really give us anything well I
tell a lie they do say that it was
trained across multiple data centers so
given that a data center maxes out at
around 32,000 gpus and I know Google
uses tpus but that still gives us a
sense about the sheer scale of Google
Gemini's compute and there is one more
task that Google Deep Mind really want
us to focus on admittedly it is very
impressive they gave Gemini 1.5 Pro a
grammar book and dictionary 250,000
tokens in total from a super obscure low
resource language the language is cang
and I had never heard of it they take
pains to point out that none of that
language was in the training data set
and so what was the result well not only
did Gemini 1.5 Pro crush gp4 it also did
as well as a human who had learned from
the same materials now we're not talking
about someone from that region of Papa
Guinea the reason a human was used for
comparison was to make that underlying
Point models are starting to approach
the learning rate at least in terms of
language of a human being and don't
forget this factors in data efficiency
same amount of data similar result next
up is what I believe to be a fascinating
graphic it shows what happens as a model
in blue Gemini 1.5 Pro is fed more and
more of a long document and of a code
database and the lower the curves go the
more accurate the model is getting at
predicting the next word what happens to
December's Gemini Pro as you feed it
more and more tokens well it starts to
get overwhelmed both in terms of code
and for long documents as the paper says
that older model and I hesitate to call
it older cuz it's just 2 months ago
they're unable to effectively use
information from the previous context
and are deteriorating in terms of
prediction quality but with Gemini 1.5
Pro the more it's fed the better it gets
even for a sequence of length a million
for documents or 10 million for code
it's quote remembering things from
millions of lines of code ago to answer
questions now I think it's significant
that when we get to sequence lengths of
around 5 to 10 million the curve
actually dips downward it no longer
follows the power law Trend that would
suggest to me that if we went up to 100
million the results would be even more
impressive here's what Google have to
say the results above suggest that the
model is able to improve its predictions
by finding useful patterns even if they
occurred millions of tokens in the past
as in the case of code and to summarize
this we already knew that lower loss
could be gotten from more compute it's a
very similar curve but what what's new
is that the power law is holding between
loss and context length as shown above
they say from inspecting longer Co token
predictions closer to 10 million we see
a phenomena of the increased context
occasionally providing outsize benefit
that could be due to repetition of code
blocks they think this deserves further
study and may be dependent on the exact
data set used so even Google aren't
fully sure what's causing that dip now
we all know that open AI kind of trolled
Google tonight by releasing Sora so soon
after Gemini 1.5 Pro but on this page I
feel Google were doing a little bit of
trolling to open AI first we have this
comparison again of retrieval and they
say they got API errors after 128,000
tokens well of course they knew that
because gpc4 turbo only supports 128,000
tokens I think they kind of wanted to
say that after this length we crush it
and with them you just get an error code
and the next bit of trolling comes here
these hyack challenges where they
secrete a phrase like this the special
magic quote City number is quote with
this the model has to retrieve the
correct City and number which is
randomized but that phrase could have
been hidden in any long text and they
chose the essays of Paul Graham now yes
this is almost certainly coincidental
but Paul Graham was the guy who fired
samman at y combinator samman disputes
that it was a firing for audio it's the
same thing even when they break down
down long audio into segments that
whisper can digest which are then
transcribed and fed to gp4 Turbo the
difference is star before you think
though that Gemini 1.5 Pro is perfect at
retrieval what happens when you feed in
100 needles into a massive Hy stack well
in that case it still massively
outperforms GPT 4 Turbo but can recall
as you can see 60 70 80% of those
needles it is not a perfect model and no
we don't have AGI and at this point
Google does state that retrieval is not
the same as reasoning they basically beg
for harder benchmarks ones that require
integrating disperate facts drawing
inferences or resolving inconsistencies
essentially reasoning if you want to
know more about how reasoning some would
say is the final Holy Grail of large
language models do check out my patreon
AI insiders I have around a dozen videos
and podcasts up as of today in fact it
was just today that I released this
video on my patreon it's a 14-minute
tour of deep fakes and features
interviews and exclusives and more if
you are a student or retired do email me
about a potential small discount now for
the final demo in coding we'll walk
through some example prompts using the
3js example code which comes out to over
800,000 tokens we extracted the code for
all of the 3js examples and put it
together into this text file which we
brought into Google AI Studio over here
we asked theel model to find three
examples for learning about character
animation the model looked across
hundreds of examples and picked out
these three next we asked what controls
the animations on the littlest Tokyo
demo as you can see here the model was
able to find that demo and it explain
that the animations are embedded within
the gltf
model next we wanted to see if we could
customize this code for us so we asked
show me some code to add a slider to
control the speed of the animation use
that kind of gooey the other demos have
this is what it looked like before on
the original 3js site and here's the
modified version it's the same scene but
it added this little slider to speed up
slow down or even stop the animation on
the Fly again with audio Gemini crush's
whisper it has a significantly lower
word error rate and for video it was
pretty funny they had to invent their
own benchmarks because the other ones
were too easy or in formal language to
bridge this evaluation Gap we introduce
a new Benchmark that was testing that
incredible feat we saw earlier of
picking out key details from long videos
now to be clear despite the demos
looking good and beating GPT 4V we're
still not close to perfect just because
Gemini 1.5 Pro can see across long
context and watch long videos doesn't
mean it's perfect at answering questions
remember that recalling facts is not the
same as reasoning or getting 100% on
multiple choice questions I also found
this part of the paper quite funny where
they try to highlight the extent of
tradeoffs of switching architecture if
it exists and the problem was they
couldn't find any across the board 1.5
Pro was just better than 1.0 Pro whether
that was math science coding multi-
linguality instruction following image
understanding video understanding speech
recognition or speech translation of
course it's obligatory at this point for
me to ding them about the accuracy level
of their mlu benchmark test test for
Gemini 1.5 Pro they say for Math and
Science it's 1.8% behind Gemini 1.0
Ultra but how meaningful is that with
this many errors just in the college
chemistry section of the MML very deep
is one admission that 1.5 Pro doesn't
seem quite as good at OCR that's optical
character recognition in other words
recognizing text from an image but
Google Cloud vision is state-of-the-art
anyway at OCR and soon enough surely
they're going to integrate that so don't
see OCR being a long-term weakness for
the Gemini series and it's hard to tell
but it seems like Google found some
false negatives in other benchmarks and
so the performance there was lower
bounding the model's True Performance
and they complain as I did in my
original smart GPT video that maybe we
need to rely more on human evaluations
for these data sets and that maybe we
should deviate from strict string
matching and there was this quite cute
section in the impact assessment part of
the paper so what are the impacts going
to be of Gemini 1.5 Pro well they say
the ability to understand longer content
enhances the efficiency of individual
and Commercial users in processing
various multimodal inputs but that
besides efficiency the model Ena
societally beneficial Downstream use
cases and they foresee Gemini 1.5 Pro
being used to explore archival content
that might potentially benefit
journalists and historians suffice to
say I think this is somewhat
underplaying the impact of Gemini 1.5
Pro just for one I think it could
transform how YouTube works or another
obvious one what about long-term quote
relationships with chatbots GPT 4's new
memory feature which seems to me like an
only slightly more advanced custom
instruction pales in comparison to
Gemini 1.5s potential you could have
discussions lasting for months with
Gemini and it might remember a detail
you said back say 6 months ago that
seems to me true memory and might
encourage enourage a kind of
companionship for some people with these
models on safety without giving too much
detail they just say it's safer than 1.0
Pro and 1.0 Ultra but later they do
admit two things first Gemini 1.5 Pro
does seem a little bit more biased it's
probably a bit harder for the model to
be anti- stereotypical when it remembers
so much also and I know this is going to
annoy quite a few people it has a higher
refusal rate that's on questions should
be both legitimately refused and not
legitimately in other words they should
have been answered of course by the time
the model actually comes out we'll have
to see if this is still the case but you
just have to take a look at my Gemini
Ultra review to see that at the moment
the refusals are pretty extreme this
could honestly be a key sticking point
for a lot of people we're drawing to an
end here but just a quick handful of
further observations you remember that
trick with chat BT where you submit the
letter A with a space say 500 times
times and it regurgitates sometimes its
training data well apparently that works
also on Gemini 1.5 Pro thing is you have
to manually repeat that character many
more times up to a million times but
with those long prompts they do admit
that it becomes easier to obtain its
memorized data I presume that's the kind
of thing that Google deepmind are
working on before they release Gemini
1.5 Pro and one more key detail from the
blog post that many people might have
missed when Gemini 1.5 Pro is released
to the public it's going to start at
just 128,000 token context window I say
just but that's still pretty impressive
and it seems to me based on the wording
of the following sentence that even that
basic version won't be free they say we
plan to introduce pricing tiers that
start at the standard 128,000 context
window so anyone hoping to get Gemini
1.5 for free seems to have misplaced
hope and then there's going to be tears
going up to 1 million tokens I'm not
sure how expensive that 1 million token
tier will be but I'll probably be on it
notice that we probably won't be able to
buy going up to 10 million tokens but I
do want to end on a positive note for
Google there was one thing I missed out
from my review of Google Gemini Ultra
and I want to make amends and that is
its creative writing ability Gemini 1.0
Ultra is simply better at creative
writing than gypt 4 and of course we're
not even talking about 1.5 Ultra how so
well Gemini varies its sentence length
we have short sentences like this debons
never really listened we also get far
more dialogue which is just much more
realistic to real creative writing
there's a bit more humor in there
whatever they did with their writing
data set they did better than open AI
GPT 4 stories tend to be far more wordy
a lot more tell not show and I'm
actually going to go one further and
prove that to you when you put GPT for
story into two state-ofthe-art
AI text detectors that's GPT 0 and
binoculars which is a new tool both of
them say most likely AI generated GPT 0
puts it at 97% for Claude we also get
most likely AI generated although GPT 0
erroneously says it's only 12% likely AI
generated that's Claude story it's way
too much to get into this video now but
remember binoculars is state-of-the-art
compared to GPT 0 but here's the punch
line this is Google Gemini story we get
from GPT 0 0% chance of being AI
generated and even the state-of-the-art
binoculars gives it most likely human
generated and I think this proves two
points first Gemini is definitely better
at creative writing and making marketing
copy by the way but too long to get into
here and second don't put your faith in
AI Tech detectors especially not in the
age of Gemini if you want to learn more
about detecting Ai and deep fakes of
course I refer you back to my deep fakes
video on my patreon AI insiders so that
is Gemini 1.5 Pro and yes this does seem
the most significant night for AI since
the release of GPT 4 as I said in my
video on January the 1 AI is still on an
exponential curve 2024 will not be a
slow year in Ai and for as long as I can
I will be here to cover it all thank you
so much for watching and have a one
wonderful day